hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that comes as a suggestion
from a subscriber uh it's from 1991 it
was played in Bogota and it features a
very cool line of the king's Gambit it's
between two Colombian players Marcio
melgosa and James laga uh so let's check
it out it's quite a wild one you guys
will enjoy it Ponte E4 with Ponte E5 not
that pawn to E5 and pawn to F4 the
king's Gambit is on the board with e
captures on F4 and now not the standard
Knight F3 but Bush of the C4 this is The
Bishop's Gambit of the king's Gambit and
it's inviting black to go for Queen Tage
for check which looks nice but it's
nothing spectacular white will play King
to F1 and later black will have to waste
the temple once white attacks the queen
with Knight to F3 and then white will
try to keep harassing The Black Queen
there are many cool games throughout
history that have um uh been played this
way so instead of just Knight to F6
ignoring white uh we have Knight the C3
defending D for pawn and now Pawn to C6
getting ready for that the D5 Central
thrust with pawn bishop to B3 D5 with e
captures and d5c characters and now Pawn
to D4 so nothing uh nothing wrong with
this with Bishop to D6 and now comes
Knight G to E2 and it's interesting that
even though this game is from 1991 uh we
reached the exact same position that uh
Jani pomishi and Levon arunan had it in
their game in the Magnus cross and
Invitational uh uh preliminaries uh
where Bishop to G4 was played and uh uh
uh arunian just destroyed nepo with this
bishop to G4 move which was sad for
Nepal because he really wanted to win
this and promote his adjustable course
on the king's Gambit but what are you
going to do Bishop to G4 is the way to
go but here we have Pawn to F3 which
which appears to be even stronger but
it's actually not g captures an F3 we
have castles and now Bishop to G5 the
white Kings defenses have been ruined on
the king side but why just doesn't care
what is black to do here to to attack
the white king So Bishop to E6 uh you
could go Rook to E8 but it's nothing uh
spectacular and you're not really
threatening anything so Bishop T6
getting um another Defender to this D5
pawn and also trying to get white to
sort of hang a piece here if Knight
captures on D5 seems like you should be
able to do this because the Knight is
pinned the problem is this queen to A5
check you will of course capture first
and then after Bishop captures Queen to
A5 check uh collects the the bishop on
D5 even if Knights the C3 defending it
now you can play Knight captures on D5
because the queen is no longer on d8 so
white ignored this white plays Queen to
D2 white wants the castle Queen side and
then put the Rooks on the G file to
attack the black king with Bishop to E7
and now Queen side castles and now again
there is a game where Knight the C6 was
played it was played in 2013 uh between
none other than vasel evanchook and
Anish giri and the vastly won that game
very nicely but here we have Knight beat
the D7 and it is now as of move 12 that
this position has never been reached
again and it concludes fairly quickly
Rook H to G1 just putting the Rook on
the nice semi-openg file uh King to h8
the problem is if you go if you go some
like Rook to see just the best of H6 and
now you're in in a whole lot of trouble
if you play G6 you just give up the rook
and if you move the Knight then you no
longer defend the D5 Pawn uh so it's
pretty bad so that's why King the a
trades you don't have to worry about
Bishop to H6 uh now comes the Knight to
the F4 just getting as many pieces as
possible as close to the black king as
possible Knights the B6 if black can
play night night the C4 black will be
very happy but white uh just ignores
that completely Queen to G2 now imagine
if the bishop was gone the queen
captures on G7 would be Checkmate so
here we have Rook the E8 Rook to G8 also
possible but black figures that it's
better to play Rook E8 and then move the
bishop to a fate to defend the G7 Pawn
so Rook Dita E1 a beautiful silent move
by white and now comes Queen to D7
adding another Defender to this bishop
on E6 but it doesn't work feel free to
pause the video and try to figure out
why this is now completely winning for
white uh while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting that uh
the the the the blacking simply cannot
be defended and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is the
best of the H6 this is the only way to
do it you don't want to capture them
Bishop captures defends the G7 Pawn uh
or play something weird this is the way
to do it uh and now you can't really
capture because Queen to G7 is Checkmate
so that's out of the question uh the G7
uh this is a a a true weakness for black
regardless of what happens to the to the
to the bishop because it's attacked
three times so here Pawn to G6 also one
of the reasons why Rook d8 was played so
white cannot capture The Rook here but
now look at the White's real idea behind
Bishop to H6 that's Rook captures on E6
uh Queen captures is impossible because
the Knight covers the E6 Square so you
have to play F characters and this now
weakens the G6 pawn and that's why the
Knight to F4 now comes uh into play very
nicely Knight captures on G6 with check
you have to capture if you don't capture
your only other option is King to G8
then you play Knight captures on E7 with
check and after the king moves Queen to
G7 will just be a Checkmate there's no
way for the black king to escape this so
you would have to play H captures on G6
but now just Queen capture Sun G6 and
there's no defense if Bishop to fade
guarding G7 you will just play bishop
captress and F6 check and after King H7
Queen to G6 check King h8 and this will
now be Checkmate so that's out of the
question so after Rook characters on E6
Knight the G8 was played this is one
last attempt for black to try and hold
everything together but now look at the
at the journey this uh this Rook
undertakes Rook captures on G6 now and
again not all that much to do uh there
are too many lines open here if you do
nothing just Bishop G7 is Checkmate so
The Rook has to be captured you could
try Knight captures but then Rook
captures on H6 you're just done uh done
a piece um there's no playing this so
instead F captures and G6 was played and
now Knight captures and G6 would check H
captures and G6 only move and now you
don't want to ruin the game by playing
Queen captures on G6 I hope none of you
were considering that because then
Bishop F6 and everything is covered
there's no way to continue the attack
but in the game after age captures and
G6 uh White just played Bishop to G7
with the check and he was in this
position on move 21 as the title
suggests that
Umaga resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here the only
way to play this is to move the king and
then Queen captures and g6's Checkmate
or to capture the bishop and then just a
nice Queen captures and G6 King to h8 or
a king to f8 or King Tage it doesn't
really matter because both ending
Checkmate now Queen to G7 will be
Checkmate but also Queen characters and
G8 will be Checkmate I myself if I have
the option of checkmating with or
without capture I will always do it
without capture because it kind of seems
cooler uh Checkmate your opponent when
he has as many pieces on the board as
possible and I think your your friends
at the bar in the library will will
agree with this so I hope uh you know
this rubs off on you at least a little
bit uh so yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it very nicely played by by
marcion uh melgosa uh very nicely done
uh in this beautiful line of the king's
gamut and like I said even though it was
played in 1991 uh we reach again a game
that was played uh between uh even Chuck
and Daniel giri where this position was
reached we're not b37 was where Knight
the C6 was played and also even even uh
sooner this position where uh
you know the theory expands we will find
new things but uh the the main ideas
have always been present and they they
are merely being improved with the help
of the engines uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys uh hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank Marilyn
schmodi Frank Brown III Stefano
Steinbach Alejandro Maldonado and the
David Kimura for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day